hey guys drop here gamescom 2015 joined
by Danny who's been playing at 3 for 16
for like 40 minutes right FIFA 16 a 16
fifa game they yeah they put you under
equals 40 minutes left you alone yeah I
was soccer a DA Nick Hammonds like I
here just going this room and play fifa
and then they forgot about me so just
play the game flick yeah usually ask me
anything you want my fifa go okay so
fifa its rates really incrementally
every single year was just you're gonna
be any different why is this year kind
of pretty different alright so Vegas Bob
my last year's game was basically it was
like a counter-attack game it was like
super fast real heavy on like the the
attackers it was relatively easy to get
around midfield get the winger's was
super class yes so it was it was a game
that was played in either box I felt
like right especially online and so in
this one I played a bunch of games i
play with the dudes are they with the
lady stop as well you don't talk about
in a bit yeah and but it felt a lot more
like a game that once you find that
balance but difficulty one not that it's
being played around the park we
distributed and developing the defenses
are a bit more robust sorry yeah it
depends a more robust and that you are
less likely to just try and like
triangle or why your way through the
fences like just go tip tip tip tip tip
and then we get a through ball and then
like if you're cross or just put it in
and get the shot away and so that's a
good defensive it's the kind of making
you pick your battles a bit more and
then in the midfield there's actually a
lot more like hugging toes total war
with so you're using for them you're
using more of the pitch basically yeah
and this is like the thing with deep is
like they have this sort of waffle
double edged sword if they've actually
made a really good football game and but
also like what do they change every year
and one of the biggest songs in last
year was just that sort of like in
balancing with the amount of player and
the pitch shines from the I know it's
only 45 minutes what I remember from
what I played it did feel like it was it
was a lot more evocative of a real
football match and also the goals
therefore were more rewarding kind of
like they aren't page like this so one
of the biggest differences mmm
this year to last is their introduction
of female team yes no the most i should
play different in the game they do and
so there's two ways you can do this
they've got an international tournament
which are 12 teams in it smut branders
you're going at the licensing they also
don't have all the teams are raining so
for instance japan are endemic but they
are 12 and female teams with all mocap
apart from that you can do friendlies as
well so they're listed under looks like
international England France and then
it's women's on the Royal in there and
when they do play differently so a lot
of a field in terms of the difference
between male and female so obviously
liked it you and the us being a team
were like I like the genuinely
fantastically good team but there is a
like the j1 they do or they day but
they're also like they're also kind of
like because the university system in
the u.s. is like really good at like
keeping too much better it's like wait
even in the UK I say are kind of a boss
my plate is damn so they were pretty
good right and but the sort of the
general feel of them is that they're not
it's not the same as I playing around
the dirt it like that the median skill
level in women's football is not the
meaning skill levels of men's football
so there is a difference in terms of
life they're more bombastic and more
agile though I holding the ball you know
you're not taking like lightning shots
from my good side the bar it's saying
that also the goalkeepers aren't as good
so there is like I won't say all right
what's the one else about this yes so
I'm not just saying like the female
seems of [ __ ] or someone on getting out
what I'm getting at is that they don't
play like if you're playing most people
have a fee for like let's be honest
everyone face pics Chelsea bar set and
ready Madrid so we are not like one
little taller yeah sorry mate so it's
not like they are on Arsenal fan so I
didn't say that so it's not like it's
not like they've like they've measured
the team's up to that level but what it
is more like is like more movement off
the ball more tapping more like tikka
taco sort of stuff wrong and also like
bursts of speed right so it's less like
you're just like driving forward it's
more like all right we're going to
collect ourselves figure out what like
player almost we're going to do and then
do it and like it felt like a different
type of thinking
school and the other thing about it is a
brand new ways to play ultimate east or
first what you saying so you're not even
calling own against on a toxin foot yeah
let's talk about [ __ ] so they have a
new one got foot draft all right all
right okay you draft your feet and it's
basically a condensed version of
ultimate team and they said they made it
because the ultimate team crowd has been
calling out for a new way to play foot
because they love playing with their
foot and so what I actually thought I
somebody who doesn't really like
ultimate team like because it takes so
much time investment it's really for the
person who plays a lot of people like
the person who like buys two or three
games a year and but what this mode is
is actually pretty interesting it's
basically 44 games you play and the
players that you get from your your
packs or the players that you pick are
like a way higher level so what you
basically get is you pick your formation
and you've all these empty slots and you
hit a button and you have to pick it
like almost notice style at the start
make sure you're picking the right play
in the right position because once you
decide like when you locked in yeah and
then you get you see board already see
if you basically pick those players you
pick your manager if you could Captain
you pick substitutions or substitutes
and then you go into a game and it's
only four games there's a buy-in for
this using their likes coins fifa points
stuffed & but you should hopefully it
says they say if you even if you won't
get win one game just get as much as you
probably want back out of it but yeah
it's like you pick a team ultimate team
and you're buying our four games so it's
kind of cool it's like it's like a
condensed version of ultimate team
without having to invest all this time
into getting and probably money into
getting all these are girls five
boroughs value cards and I wish it
wasn't behind out like cities coin
paywall thing but
other you know you always accrued at
self are playing the game anyway so
it'll be a nice thank you so much for a
detailed breakdown and for the latest on
as FIFA 16 stay tuned to gamespot